let's do a hard segue into this story uh
with Alex Jones we have this from
timcast.com quote burning hell Hitler
Alex Jones comments on yay interview
quote I felt like I was sucked into a
giant publicity stunt said the Infowars
host so uh everybody remembers what
happened when you went on Alex Jones He
also went on with Gavin McGinnis and I
guess what what Alex was saying is that
before the show they agreed not to talk
about that stuff then when the show went
on the air that's all they talked about
and he feels like it was a big publicity
stunt
I I think Alex uh his comments were
pretty interesting he said that uh yay
Kanye had a fifth grade level
understanding of Hitler he also
challenged Nick Fuentes to a debate
about history and specifically World War
II there was also a reference to him
potentially being a homosexual uh so so
Alex kind of kind of went off a little
bit here I don't know if he felt
pressure but we got to understand Alex
was the man that has been talking about
um the Prescott Bush he's been talking
about Margaret Sanger he's been talking
about a lot of American Elites financing
this larger Eugenics depopulation Nazi
World War II kind of movement
um this was kind of his moment to kind
of Bring It Back some people are saying
he should have brought it back when yay
was on and pushed back a little bit more
but that's up to people's own
interpretations of how they saw the
interview I don't know what did you
think of that interview and what do you
think about his latest comments now
talking about fifth grade level
understanding of uh World War II I think
that the interview that Alex stayed with
hea was really important because it
highlighted why the first amendment is
important in the sense of the reason why
I'm a free speech absolutist is because
I think that you should allow your enemy
or just anybody in society right to
really say what they think about certain
issues I think that free speech is so
effective because it essentially allows
people to expose themselves to expose
what they really think to expose and
allows the public as well to decide if
their views are good or bad so I think
you know yay going on with Alex Alex not
really pushing back was a good way for
the public to really I guess delve into
what Kanye actually thought about this
issue regarding what Alex is saying now
um I do think that Kanye is being used
by the people that are around him I'll
be honest with it can you disagree with
me on this look when we hear that Alex
you know Alex is saying that they agree
not to talk about this stuff about
Hitler and all that and then they did
anyway and he felt like it was a
publicity stunt that's exactly what I
was saying it felt like exactly like the
whole thing was planned out so a couple
points maybe it's being a dead horse but
you know uh yay went on with Kevin
McGinnis we'll talk about that but a
couple points like they initially asked
us for a return flight right after the
show we couldn't do it it was not that
we were told by the uh we couldn't get a
flight it was impossible they ended up
getting a private plane ready to go
right afterwards they also said we'll
talk about the campaign the plans and
then immediately jumped into this stuff
same thing to do with Alex Jones so uh
the other thing too is when I look at
what happened with Gavin McGinnis yay is
just saying the craziest possible things
he's doing it again I want to give a
shout out to Viva Frey and uh Robert
Barnes because Barnes made a really
really great Point uh something that we
missed obviously and it's that yay's
talking about this tax liability that
he's got 50 million dollars or whatever
and they're trying to put him in jail
and he was saying that we didn't notice
and we should have pressed on it he's
right
maybe yay is trying to appear crazy so
he doesn't go to prison so that he can
come off as like mentally unwell he
didn't intentionally what did what did
Barnes say the example he gave was that
yay is going to come out with the
defense that the reason he didn't pay
taxes he was scared that I was going to
go to the Jewish people or something
like that like he'll he'll make up an
excuse so it sounds like he's unhinged
and then he gets a slap on the rest
minimum security thing instead of like a
serious attack 25-year tax evasion thing
so so yay goes on with gav McGinnis and
he says he what do you do he called for
Jewish people to forgive Hitler it's
just just really really out there is is
putting it lightly I mean it's nuts it's
nuts and uh in it this is amazing Gavin
McGinnis is like when you meet someone
you judge them like by the individual
right he's like I don't yeah just
outright says it there's there's no way
okay like here's here's my issue I think
Barnes may be right about him trying not
to not to go to jail for tax evasion or
whatever the issue is but like it seems
like Kanye is
is is pretending to be crazy poorly you
know what I mean like Maybe not maybe
because people believe it they're like
how could he say such things like well
he's just saying stupid crazy and
outrageous look he's always been crazy
and outrageous that's why for me I feel
like it's him being used by the people
around him to push his specific message
or narrative you know whether or not he
agrees with that
I I don't know I've been a Kanye West
fan for a long time I also have not met
him in person like you guys have so I
feel like my commentary is based on what
I'm seeing in the headlines you guys
have more of a background he was totally
different yeah before the camera off
camera totally different and I kind of
wish we kind of filmed a little bit just
to give people a perspective because
everything was very cordial very you
know understanding a lot of the
craziness and nonsense wasn't there and
then the cameras went on it was like a
different person it was sitting there a
different vibe a different energy and
everything just changed the room see I
think he got just like MK Ultra by
Hollywood so but this is the thing
everything we're hearing like the things
that announce Jones the thing is that on
Gavin McGinnis the things he said here
is only what people saw publicly that's
why I thought the behind the scenes
scenes things with them that we did was
so important because for whatever reason
he was you watch that video and he's
just like yeah he's very very calm very
chill he's like walking to Luke and he's
like we got to figure out how to get
better food in this house he looks at me
he's like we should put him in charge of
getting the food that'd be really great
yeah totally different camera goes on
and he's losing he he appears to lose it
it looks like a performance he goes on
Alex Jones wearing a Balenciaga [ __ ]
mask and then he's he's got a net and
he's going you'll be meaning with them
we're gonna take your kids and it's
you're you're looking at this like is
this guy of his mind but you see him off
camera before the show and he's having
an intelligent normal conversation with
you as soon as the camera turns on come
on man AJ Alex Jones Is Right put some
money in the jar whoever's here go down
to where Alex Jones's right there put
money in he said he felt like he was in
one big publicity son I think he's right
yeah but at the same time in in a court
of law you know being you know allegedly
anti-semitic isn't an excuse for an
insanity though what Barnes was saying
is that Kanye will come out and say he
didn't pay taxes because you know it's
going to go to all the Jewish people who
control everything that would be his his
weird crazy excuse or something it'd be
interesting to look at the what was it
Wesley Snipes
I think that was the example that he
referenced it would be interesting to
look at that particular case and see
exactly what happened there just to get
a reference of how that that that
previously played out to how you know
what what might be the strategy here but
who knows at the end of the day what are
you thinking well I'm glad you're more
more of an empath than intuitive person
I was thinking about this as like of the
long term like where is this along the
path of humanity when we look back in a
thousand years like what what was
happening right now and what will they
remember it happening I think what's
happening is
crazy it is is Kanye's waking up a bunch
of Jewish people and pointing them to
God like last night on that Gavin
against interview I'll explain it Gavin
was like I don't know about that one Ian
yeah Gavin's like because Nick was
saying oh there's a cabal or they were
saying there's a cabal of people that
are preventing Kanye from you know
getting to another Echelon of wealth or
whatever there's cabal and kind of like
it's the Jewish people and uh Gavin was
like I I don't think they're Jewish if
you don't believe in God you're not
Jewish and it's something I said last
week too so Gavin if you're listening
hell yeah dude nice one and it's true
and I think no no that's that's not true
let me finish please I I understand but
I wanna I wanna like if you make a point
just explain if you make like 12 points
in a row we can't address all it's
called the Gish Gallop so when you said
a few things right now that I think need
to be addressed one you can be
ethnically Jewish and not religious yeah
well I think you need a different word
for that okay well that's that's that's
an important thing to make one two two
it's like saying the word means two
different things it's nonsense the word
means something what does the word mean
what does Jewish mean okay let's define
it and move on you know maybe two
definitions you can say religiously or
you can say ethnically then right well
I'm talking about I'm just talking about
the word what does the word mean let's
be specific the word means that you're
Jewish meaning what that you're a Jew
meaning what do you believe in God
that's the tenet of Judaism that's like
the tenet I'm pretty sure we have people
here who are ethnically Jewish their
parents were like if your
great-great-grandparents were Jewish
then that doesn't mean that you are you
got to believe in it it's a process it's
like an understanding uh this is my
thoughts are that what's going to happen
is people are realizing like if you're
falling if you're a fallen Jew if you've
like no longer believed in this and
you're just this atheist taking
advantage of people you're going to
realize that God is is great that it's
like it's there for all of us so we're
all in this together and I think that
what's happening is there's a
there's there's going to be a revelation
within Judaism and probably all the
major religions on Earth that there's
going to be some sort of transformation
where people come back to the faith and
Kanye will be looked at someone that
saved the Jews a Reformation yeah I just
have to say in because he returned him
to God I I think this may be one of the
most insane things I've ever heard you
sure man I'm talking about what people
it's dude people let me just often told
they're crazy when they're talking about
stuff like let me just clarify a few
things Kanye West said he wouldn't he
said Jewish people aren't allowed to be
in control of things he said the only
way he would allow them to work for them
if he could put cameras in their houses
and spy on them and and you think that's
him saving them well I think Savannah's
on is something that Nick has been
tweaking his mind the last two weeks
with a bunch of anti-Semitic stuff Nick
when he was pressed when Gavin told Nick
I don't think they're Jewish I think you
if you don't believe in God you're not
Jewish and Nick was like okay maybe
these people aren't Jewish maybe it's
Godless people atheists okay maybe but
then immediately Nick switched to like
but Jesus Christ is the is the King and
is the great God and it's the same stuff
Kanye's been splattering like this deep
Christian belief stuff like you got to
get out of that and become like so yeah
but I agree with you Kanye has said some
madly racist stuff in the last and or or
see that's the thing is it race it's not
even a race it's a religion it's so
confusing on purpose there's there
there's an ethnicity as well it's the
only religion on Earth that happens
you look like you want to say something
this might get me canceled but my
legitimate question I guess for the
entire movement because you know what
I'm at the point where I do feel like
the term anti-Semitism has been
extremely overused I am and I want to
know your guys's viewpoint on okay can
we legitimately criticize the Jewish
Community or people who are Jewish that
are in power are we allowed to criticize
that or is that anti-Semitism because I
think what this is linking to is that
broader conversation and I think a lot
of people in the right wing do have that
question I would like your guys's
viewpoints on it because I think this is
something that a lot of people
question but we don't really talk about
I think if you just hate somebody you
know that that's hatred that's because
of how they were born or how they look
or their religion that that's wrong but
I think government should be criticized
no matter what kind of government it is
including the you know Israeli
government or or Israeli individuals so
I think that's the distinction that I
see myself Gavin again McGinnis made a
point he said when you meet someone
there are blanks let you treat them as
an individual and so the issue with with
the yay stuff is
uh he mentioned Jon Stewart uh I
mentioned Dave Chappelle they both made
a similar point in Hollywood and media
there's a lot of Jewish people the
problem is Kanye explicitly stated in
more than one interview he lumps all of
them together regardless of of what that
really means so like I think I think the
issue is if you take a look at Harvard
Asian people are overrepresented in
Harvard because it does not mean you go
up to an Asian person and be like this
person must be good at math you know
it's it's you treat the individual like
the individual Me growing up uh in
Chicago with my friends we had some
Asian friends who are as dumb as a box
of rocks then of course you see the
tropes about certain things what we end
up what I end up learning I should say
in my view the reason Asians may be
overrepresented in Harvard is because
the culture that that they inherit its
cultural elements are studiousness and
punctuality and it's like strictness and
authoritativeness and authoritarian like
we see in the Chinese Communist party so
you look at people who come from that
culture they're going to have a very
very distinct and strict way of raising
their kids those kids are more likely to
exhibit certain behaviors like they're
going to be studious if I were to come
out and just be like wow that proves it
Asian people are all one way or another
it's just not correct so the issue is
when people say the issue is Jewish
people it's the same thing as the left
saying Asians should have a higher
standard to get in college because
they're Asian and I'm like no none of
that a person comes up to me I say who
are you what do you want what does this
mean I don't think Asians are conspiring
to get into colleges Asians are suing to
keep people out of colleges well there
are people who are Asian who are suing
Harvard but it's because Harvard's
making it hard on these individuals who
may not have I'll put it this way poor
working-class Asian people being told
they can't go to Harvard is to me
completely insane completely insane and
I'm not going to blame all Asian people
for filing lawsuits against Harvard
because Harvard is concerned that more
Asians means less Hispanics or black
people you know I think it's all white
guys that are responsible for all of our
wrongs are of our ills everything wrong
in this Society is because of white guys
I say that as a proud person of color
and uh when whenever we do this I I
think it needs to be called out
especially when it comes to kind of
generalizations I think we should always
try to be more specific but again if you
have hatred for somebody that's that's
just because of the the way they are
that's just wrong that's just how I
plainly see it see and okay so this is
my legitimate questioning too and for
example Kyrie Irving Nike just dropped
him right because he shared a link to an
allegedly anti-semitic documentary I've
never seen the documentary myself so
maybe it is anti-Semitic I'm not sure
but when people call that out and say
okay why do we see this consistent
pattern of people sharing something the
the media immediately labeling it as
anti-Semitism this person getting
canceled this is a pattern that we have
seen a time or two why is it that we're
not allowed to speak about this again
this is just me questioning these things
but but we are speaking about it right
now
the story about Kyrie Irving has been
talked about a whole lot and uh it's
cancel culture and we think it's wrong
like Luke has the Kyrie Irving Jersey
that he puts up periodically I think
people should be entitled to free speech
they should be allowed like in 2018 when
Twitter started Banning people alt-right
individuals I did an interview with
insiders Oliver Darcy saying like this
is wrong they shouldn't be doing this
right it it it's weird to me that you
people are acting like the issue with uh
Kanye West and what do you think about
Jewish people is unique I'm like what
are you talking about like there's tons
of instances where people have said
something offensive and then gotten
canceled over it and we've argued that
shouldn't be happening right yeah what
happened to Kyrie is absolutely insane
and I think he had a big Target on his
back especially with what happened
within the last few years with him
standing up for uh his personal freedom
to choose not to be vaccinated he was
punished by a lot of people the
corporate media attacked him and I think
they're they're just looking for any
reason just to try to get him out of the
the discourse just to try to stop him as
much as they can and he literally
tweeted a a I don't think it was even a
link I think it was a photo I think it
was a poster for a documentary they also
tried to get him in trouble for posting
clips from Alex Jones so he he's an
individual that I routinely put you know
the Jersey behind because I think he's
unfairly punished I I think a lot of the
stuff that he's going through is
absolutely ridiculous he donated a half
a million dollars to the ADL he
apologized for sharing a link without
even giving it any excuse me for sharing
a photo of a documentary without even
giving it any context and and they still
decided to play him and cancel it that's
oh that's over and that's crazy and I
agree with you that's something that
deserves pushback on but when someone is
hateful against someone else they should
be called out as well right it's it's
and it's not unique to Jewish people
I'll give you a few examples Netflix
executive who was I think in 2018 was
giving examples of of hate speech saying
the slurs so people in the meeting went
to the exec went to HR and complained
yeah they called him in and they said
what did you say it's like I was
explaining these are words that
shouldn't be used on Netflix specials
what words he said they went they fired
him you had the race car driver race car
driver whose dad in the 80s used the
n-word on the radio so sponsors pulled
out from him he didn't even do anything
cancel culture is insane I I I think
it's and and I get all of the the woke
crazy uh leftist organizations writing
articles about it because I said the
Alex Jones interview with yay was good
because it shows us exactly what yay
believes and immediately people were
like hey man I don't want to be
Associated I don't like that that those
are bad ideas
I don't think we should shut down
people's lives take away their bangs
destroy everything because they think
things that I think are stupid or wrong
right I think we we just speak up we
have conversations like this and explain
why we think they're right yeah I mean
look what happened to Salman Rushdie a
couple weeks ago I mean that deserves to
be discussed I think uh if we're going
to be talking about a lot of this stuff
when we're going to be talking about
this conversation again uh I think
blanketly it's just very easy to say Hey
you hate somebody because of the the way
that they're they're born you're a
jackass and I think it's that simple and
I think at the end of the day we should
be going to that and not just using this
as a way to divide and conquer people
and use it as a way to control speech
and to punish people for daring to
express ideas uh because I I think we
also reached the stage in our society
where comedy is being banned where it's
being vilified where it's being stopped
comedy used to bring people together it
used to make people laugh about our
differences we can't even have that
anymore we just have people are afraid
to even speak to each other and that to
me is is an absolutely dangerous
ingredient towards a society that is on
the verge of collapsing let me let me
give another example Dave Chappelle and
Jon Stewart both came out and made these
statements that that Kanye and I
actually mentioned Jon Stewart said
something to the effect of if you can't
if you overuse the phrase anti-semitic
when someone points out there are a lot
of Jewish people in Hollywood or in
Media or in finance then this is what is
breeding the conspiracies basically it's
what's making people feel like their
ideas may be correct and if you want to
have an honest conversation you start
with yes we we do see in certain areas
of representation that was Jon Stewart
Dave Chappelle made the joke where he
said if it's an Italian guy it's the mob
if it's a black guy it's a gang and if
it's a bunch of Jewish people it's a
coincidence how to talk about it that
was Dave Chappelle's joke Jon Stewart
and Dave Chappelle's lives have not been
destroyed they've talked about it
they've addressed it it's come up here
the thing about what Kanye said is Kanye
praised Hitler yeah he's on a different
level Kanye said they're not allowed to
control things and he would only hire
them if he can follow them home put
cameras in their house to prove they
aren't Spies Like okay if you said that
about any ethnic group people are gonna
get mad at you yeah well I mean I think
Kanye has just been an interesting
example of bringing this conversation to
the Forefront and again too it really
was a test of freedom of speech right
and who in our in the right wing I guess
area really is truly pro-free speech
because granted I don't agree with a lot
most of what Kanye said probably all of
what Kanye said it was pretty crazy but
again still support his right to say it
same thing with Nick Fuentes I still
support their right to say and I think
that's the beauty of the Free Speech
Free Speech right is you allow your
opponent to say exactly what they think
or just anybody in society exactly what
they think and then Society is allowed
to dictate if they like it or not well
you let the best idea win and you have
to counter bad ideas with good ideas
that's why I think we were trying to
facilitate a conversation here to try to
find out what the best idea was and
sadly we didn't have that but it would
have been you know contentious it would
have been interesting but I think it's
worthwhile to challenge bad ideas and I
think we need to do this more routinely
than than a lot of other people do it
when you we we got a Super Chat that I
want to address before we go to super
chats because someone just mentioned is
an interesting point they said you're
still not listening to Sav she's asking
why you can say collusion between white
people white person abuses people but
it's not okay to say Jewish person
so let me explain from where I come from
my point is I have routinely ragged on
the left for blaming white people it
will not be any different when someone
wants to blame Jewish people I do not
like people looking at someone and being
like you know what I've made a decision
about you just because you look a
certain way that's nonsense to me I just
don't I don't think it's legitimate I've
met I remember I knew this Haitian guy
when I worked at O'Hare and he was
complaining how people call him
African-American but he's from Haiti
he's like he's not from Africa he's not
American either he's Haitian don't call
me that it's like this stupid like
judging a person for this I agree the
left when they blame white people for
everything is ridiculous and it's wrong
I also think it's wrong when people like
Kanye or anyone else blame Jewish people
for it I also think it's wrong with
people blame black people for it I'm
like let's blame criminals let's blame
thieves let's let's blame corruption and
let's try to figure out how uh we live
and work together and we don't blame
each other just because we look a
certain way because I I just may man I'm
imagining just just the idea of just
racism in general it really does make me
angry same yeah like judging someone in
any capacity without actually knowing
who they are and knowing what they
believe is a problem because then what
you're going to be a person who likes
white people okay guess what all the
antifa people overwhelmingly white so
it's certainly not white people that are
good or better no because Auntie was out
of their out of their minds then you've
got Latinos you've got people from Cuba
who love America more than these white
antifa yeah I just you know that's just
me that's just me I'm saying they're
self-hating white people just like
there's Jewish people name systems that
breed these kinds of problems like the
Roman Empire is the white the white
person problem is the Roman patriarchy
that thing created a church to get into
people's minds it tried to control the
world it's still trying to control the
world through its Church like that's the
white person problem is the Roman
patriarchy that's a real thing the
Jewish problem is the banking cartels
that were invented by am shell
Rothschild in the 1500s his three sons
went off to England Italy and Fran
chance to make the Rothschild banking
Empire it's the banking superstructure
that's the problem not the race or the
culture doesn't matter what you look
like it's the behavior and I think I
think Jones actually made that point and
then yay admitted he was wrong he said
he shouldn't have blanketed all people
and that it's actually about Banking and
stuff like that see and that's the thing
that's the thing with Kanye that's
inconsistent with his interviews ill
like when he does get that push back
he's like okay well hope
point you know we looked up the CEOs of
banks because we're talking with Michael
malice and it's like the CEOs a bunch of
these banks are just white dudes yeah
it's so it's I don't know man
this is the problem I have mainly it's
because I want to solve these problems
why is the Federal Reserve ripping
people off and destroying everything
well if you come out and just scream
that someone's like religious background
or ethnic background I'm like bro that
bro that's not the problem is the system
and it's being supported by a whole
bunch of people of all different
backgrounds yeah how are you going to
solve anything by saying you know
specifically you know focusing on some
of the outer details rather than the
actual core issues of the problem and
the effects of it it's like this it's
like a homeless white man has privilege
and Oprah Winfrey is disadvantaged yeah
sorry dude I'm not buying that when they
come out and they say white people this
is white heteronormative patriarchy I'm
like shut up dude in New York City they
implemented uh resources in the official
School Board there that made sure this
is this is at the the head of the
Department of Education in New York City
that if you're a white student that's
poor resource shouldn't be going to you
they should be going to a rich black
person a black kid mainly because of the
institutionalized racism inside of that
that school or structure that's the
policies that are being implemented
right now that are absolutely insane
that need to be pushed back on and are
racist you know for the record when it
comes up against Semite is uh more than
just an error or more than just a Jew
it's an Arab it's Phoenician Acadian
it's all those people from that
Southwestern Asian Peninsula or area not
really Peninsula those are all semites
so if you hated Muslims during 2005 you
were an anti-semite buddy if you had if
you have anti-muslim in you you're
anti-semite I don't like that that they
they act like it's only Jewish it's like
there's a lot of people the Semitic
people were a lot of different people
right it's just another word for racism
essentially that's what the ethnic and
religious thing I think may have been
getting confused for you there but it
should be very clear when you use that
word what it means it does not mean
Jewish person there's there's tough
challenges in the space you know ever I
I think everybody gets it I grew up on
the south side of Chicago
47th Street was just north of us when
you crossed it the entire Community was
black there was an area they called the
Leclair courts when people from uh when
black people from north of 47th would
come down south of 47th and then there
was this thing where a bunch of young
girls would Rob young girls south of
47th and it was always a racial
disparity you'd see a lot of that the
cops wouldn't let you go north of 47th
and I'm like
look man I'm not stupid enough to think
that this is the problem of someone's
race it's a problem of two distinct
communities that don't see each other
and it may be a component of race that's
why they don't view each other as like
part of the same Community but a lot of
it was constructed a lot of the project
housing the redlining the blockbusting
created this element so when you go into
areas where it's like mixed everybody's
getting along right so I think what
happens is a lot of people see something
like that they see these barrier streets
in New York I lived in Crown Heights and
there was a split between the Jewish
neighbor and the black neighborhood and
they had shootouts because they were
rival drug dealers right A lot of people
thought it was like a race war or an
ethnic thing and then you and then I
learned from the people actually
involved they were like nah it's just
because they're trying to sell drugs
over here and so why is it that they
were it was tended to be black people
fighting against Jewish people was not
the race it was that if you lived in
this area the dealers you were working
with it was a Jewish neighborhood if you
lived in this area the deals you're
working with it was in a black
neighborhood this is like a deep problem
in in cities with racial segregation and
there's a lot of uh components to it
that I think are real notably that
people choose to live in areas where
people look like each other that is what
you know creates racism me per or as a
component of it me personally I'm gonna
try to avoid stereotyping someone based
on experiences like that and let someone
be an individual so they can uh be as
worthy as they choose used to be yeah
man there's groups and cabals and gangs
are real they're real people can get
together and sometimes you know you you
get with what you know a lot of times
that's the easiest thing path of least
resistance if you speak the same
language if I don't know if they look
like you maybe it's easier to to
identify but Jessica's groups are real
doesn't mean that people aren't
individuals when you see their eyeballs
you realize the skin suit is almost
irrelevant the brain stem creature is
like what we really are floating in
these meat sacks pulling on electrodes
getting our bodies to move around but
you see the humanity in their eyes man
you get right through that right through
that I thought racism was gone in 2008
for for there was a brief moment of a
year where everyone was the same and I
used that word hyperbolically because I
know we have genetic differences but
we're so similar
so freaking similar in group out group
situation yeah I'll tell you this we
look at that that poll that data that
shows that white Liberals are the only
group with an outgroup preference that
shows that among black people Asian
people let Latino they have an in-group
racial preference they are slightly more
inclined to want to be around people who
are of the same ethnic background or
Race White conservatives same thing it's
slight it's not definitive liberals the
only with a negative they don't like
being around white people that's
interesting yeah so I think Tucker
Carlson had the nail on that with a
hammer when he said he was like I'm not
racist it's white liberal women they're
the ones who are voting for all these
policies and doing all these things I
was a white liberal I'm like is that
racist and sexist though because you're
you're calling out white white women I
didn't like being around only people I
was born in Chicago Falls they call it
Caucasian Falls because it's like 99.9
white people and I was disgusting like
until I was 18 it was like racist and I
left went to New York City Chicago La I
just wanted to be around different
cultures that was the white liberal in
me I couldn't stand just being isolated
in this one monocle why was it
disgusting because I knew there was more
I knew that racism wasn't right it
didn't sound right I knew that how is it
racist if there was like overwhelmingly
white they would make racist jokes about
other people other races and stuff and
it was just like okay if you if you if
you were like no that's not good then
you could ostracized by the group of
racists and so my I'm forced like it's a
little guy I want to say they're all
racist but I think they're just inherent
racism in all of us from that
environment where it's like that was
normal and our parents had come from
racist environments
um I had to get out of it I had to see
the world
um then I went to South America man
that's like the other end of the
spectrum where I was the odd man out and
that was that was a very lonely
experience too anyway I advise everyone
get a chance to dip into another culture
I live down a normal Avenue in L.A and I
said
what does that mean it's like the the
Latina men they're getting Wild on
Sunday you know they got the food carts
going and all this dancing and playing
music at church we used to have the
elotes carts in this on the South Side
by Venom Park where I hang out and then
the mayor banned them yeah they were
only allowed on the other side of Cicero
where all the Billboards turned Spanish
that was deeply offensive to me because
it was like it was the most fun thing
when the Lotus cart pulled up you had a
dollar and he shaved the corn into the
cup with some mayo some Parmesan some
red some cayenne pepper Stir It Up hand
it to you yeah a cup of corn and then
and then we don't know why but he would
but there was like a rule put in place
Banning them from from the west side of
Cicero Avenue yeah and that just happens
to be like a dividing line where you
start seeing more more Hispanic and
Spanish Billboards and we were like yo
what the man we love the elotes guy he
was cool and somalis he had tamales too
it was so great to just witness the
humanity and people of other of the it's
not race it's not the word race isn't
the right word what's the word what's
the difference between like someone from
Africa and someone from Ireland I guess
different cultures different cultures
but if we're both born in the United
States and we grew up across the street
from each other then what's the
difference what would you go to America
yeah I would still say it's more of a
culture thing though right yeah but you
said you felt isolated in South America
that was interesting because I had the
lightest skin long hair they would call
me Thor from the movie because they were
like and
um and when I walk on the street I just
people would be staring at me and
looking at me and it was like I didn't
speak their language very well it was a
very weird experience I have a lot of
more empathy towards people that might
identify an out group now yo I went to
Thailand during uh Chinese New Year
where'd you go uh Bangkok oh cool and I
can't remember exactly where we were but
it was this like big big Market Avenue
that went really far and it was just
crowded shoulder to shoulder with people
I could see over everyone's head it was
just um you know and like the person I
was with we were both like on average
taller than everyone and I was like I
was like wow like we're in this country
everyone here is Thai I'm like a foot
taller than everybody I'm like or like
you know half a foot taller than
everybody then I went to Sweden and I
was just like looking up at everybody
like this is very interesting yeah you
know everybody was taller than a good
conversation to have is the conversation
about genetics and the difference of
genetics they call it race realism
sometimes like but I think that's an
important Free Speech conversation to
objectively identify differentials in
genetics but also acknowledge the
similarity in our Consciousness and our
brains and our spines and stuff like
that
um but you got to be able to like with
love acknowledge the differences
what is that uh just like the big it's a
famous Market in Bangkok I'd like to
check out the name I don't know I went
to this mall that was insanely huge
though in Bangkok where they were like
one of the biggest malls in the world or
something like that yeah I don't know
also before we're gonna go to super
chats but I want to give a shout out to
Roberto Jr uh our rooster because
there's just something hilarious about
when you so you know they're like a foot
and a half tall but when you walk in
there Roberto Jr turns his head up to
look you in the eyes and I just think
it's funny because I'm like he doesn't
need to see my face like what you know I
don't know it's just funny like he can
see you and see what you're doing but he
wants to look up at your face and he
turns his head sideways to look at you
this is a funny thing interesting he's
like what are you doing he's like okay
he's got to see your face right in India
I think they say dolphins and elephants
are people they give them personhood oh
wow non-human people thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time